[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get to randy johnson here in a
moment
last week we had dave robertson dodgers
manager
and somehow we ended up with a
conversation in a story about when dave
roberts went to the plate and actually
tried to bunt on randy johnson here's
the dodgers manager
i didn't get the chance to hit the homer
off randy because he drove me in the
ribs anyway
yeah so i got the the repercussion of
getting hit by ranch i guess i could
have had him sign that ball what did it
feel like
i still feel it um it was that it was 97
to seemer
and uh it was opening day maybe 2003. i
tried a bunt
um and then the ball went foul and juan
pierre always told me said hey man if
you try to burn off randy he's like the
nolan ryan guy where if you bunt you
better make it fair because if you don't
the next one's going to be in your ribs
and
i swear daddy it was like
he's up there with this big black glove
right under his eyes and you got that
visual and i think it was i swear it was
like the top gun radar lock right on my
ribs and i could just sense it and then
it was this heat-seeking 97 two-seamer
just running right into my rib that's
dave roberts the dodger manager randy
johnson the big unit joining us on the
program why was it offensive if somebody
tried to bunt on you
i'm not aware of that at all dan
[Laughter]
because isn't that the ultimate
compliment to you randy i can't hit you
i i might be able to bunt to get on but
you and nolan ryan took it personally
yeah i'm not really sure i'm not sure of
uh you know nolan's reasons and
you know there was a lot of people that
bunnered off me uh
um and maybe that was you know they were
doing the best that they could do uh to
use uh their ability to get on base i
guess i just i didn't see it anyway
other than you know i was just going to
make it tough for you to get on base
regardless whether you were swinging the
bat or button
do you remember hitting dave roberts
i don't
but but i'm sure your engineers could
probably look up how many batters i hit
and i and and and i think it's a legit
question i think there's
i'm close to being at the top of hit
batters in major league baseball
well you did pitch to your 45 so you're
going to hit a few how many how many did
unit hit pulling he had 190 but uh he
really peaked in 92-93 when he led the
league and hit batsman
there you go did you ever feel sorry for
somebody you hit
uh my mom
a father son a mother-son game you you
plunked your mom yeah wiffle ball in the
backyard one summer
it was it was a couple of weeks ago
actually
[Laughter]
and your mom's 6 10 as well so
yeah and she's 94.
[Laughter]
what could you give me now you're gonna
you're going to be what 59 coming up
here 59 i think
59 and uh i think before we continue any
further i should uh
talk about the disclosure of anything i
say does not represent my employer
family or friends
and uh because because today's april 1st
okay
with that being said let's continue now
okay
if you
if you got six weeks to get ready
what would you what what do you think
you could throw
what would be your top end
uh well dan i've had three back
surgeries five knee surgeries and my
last year i retired when i was 46
actually not 45. okay
uh and with san francisco and i actually
tore my my uh
a rotator cuff
and i never had surgery i just kind of
let it scar over if you will so
i'm not really sure
how effective i would be
uh or how scary i would be out there uh
i might be a little bit vulnerable not
being able to throw 95 to 100.
what is the motivation to play into your
40s you know we look at tom brady some
other athletes nolan ryan i think was 45
but do you remember you're financially
set
your legacy is set
what is it that keeps you going
because at that point in my career i was
having more fun than i had ever had
the expectations weren't quite as great
as they once were at the peak of my
career and now i was more of a a mentor
if you were uh when i was with san
francisco barry zito tim lincecum matt
kane sanchez
that's why they had me come to san
francisco so i could be more of a mentor
and
going out there
and with the wind at my back at a t and
t park
throwing 91 on a good day
was great yeah and you know i was
pitching to more contact back then and
would try to get a double play and for
me back then
that was success and i just loved the
game
and uh you know i might have even tried
to play another year had i not tore my
my rotator cuff
but you look at your style in today's
game where it's basically you throw it
hard and i swing really hard
how would how would your career be
different with today's philosophy with
hitting and pitching
if i was in my prime plane today's game
with the way the game's being played
today i'd have 400 strikeouts
in a season
in a season well yeah i mean i i i came
close a couple of years uh in the years
that i played back then um
and people were swinging hard back then
but now
i think analytics has really taken over
and and in some ways it's it's a very
important
uh part of the game
but i don't think it's really important
to know what the extra velocity was
uh i know when i'm 60 feet six inches
away from the hitter and i give up a
home run i know by the crack of the bat
and the velocity the ball is going over
my head nine out of ten times i know
when it's a home run i don't need to
know
you know what the extra velocity was 125
miles an hour what was that sound like
when you know that you've given up a
home run uh the face on the baseball you
know those old cartoons that you used to
see when the face on the baseball is
going by you screaming it's like warped
it's like going yeah exactly
yeah and there was a few of those
hormones that i gave up that were like
that
well mcguire's that was a bomb but yeah
do you even turn around when you give up
that home run i don't even remember no
no we were we were teammates at usc and
it was in the kingdome
and uh
i actually i actually struck out 19 in
that game
i struck out 19 in that game
and uh and i was remember and we lost
the game
and he hit that prolific home run
and when he rounded the bases
uh and he got into the old kingdome
there up in seattle he sat in the
doorway right between the benches and i
kind of saw him and i just gave him a
tip of the hat and he gave me one back
and you know that was a friendship that
we had being old teammates from college
yep that's just i got it i'm gonna throw
it you swing if you hit it good for you
yeah
i knew the extra velocity was pretty
good
your name came up yesterday we had
barkley on and barkley we thought was
going to welcome us to his home during
super bowl week in arizona and then we
find out we're only there for a morning
we don't get to go in the house and i go
damn i should reach out to randy johnson
you know you would be more hospitable
than barkley
this is exactly what i heard dan
this is what i heard in this and i'm so
glad that we've connected because i do
want to be a host
in fact
have a cigar
from the white house
exactly a humidor from the white house
oh look at this there's the open door
policy
how big how big is the house though
the house is about 25 000 square feet
okay
what did what did charles call his place
affectionately a compound
a compound but wasn't it called like the
barkley something i called it the
barkley center uh that that that's cute
dan thank you randy thank you
uh
is this an invitation
when you're the mvp of the only
championship in the valley of the sun
your millions of fans simply know you as
and reside at
area
you'll fifty-one all security clearance
when you stay on my compound
what do we have there what kind of toys
do we have when we get to the randy
johnson compound area 51. you have an
assortment of high-performance sports
cars gassed and charged and ready to go
you'll have nothing but the finest wine
and champagne look at that
you will be staying in the west wing
you will have a 5 000 square foot
recording studio that opens up to the
grotto where there's an entertainment
center out there for your recording of
the super bowl
long stay there
damn
uh can we take bp against you
well that's a disclaimer that you're
gonna have to sign
maybe we don't do that that that might
not go well i
i
i'm rolling out the welcome mat and the
red carpet why charles didn't decide to
do that i have no idea no he's not as
generous as you
and then he said something about how i'm
not so friendly i don't know where that
came from i've been retired for 11 years
there might have been a point in your
career where you weren't friendly randy
there might have been might have been
yeah
on game day yeah yeah oh i found that
out the hard way um hey great to talk to
you and uh we'll stay in touch but
thanks for joining us
all right take care all right that's
randy johnson hall of famer now that
that's how you welcome somebody to the
volley mr arizona yes
i mean we don't need charles barkley